when i die i want these burnt and mixed
in with my ashes
and spread over the beach that's not
true but maybe
maybe we'll see
[Music]
what's going on it's chase stokes and
these are my essentials
first essential i actually have on my
wrist because
it's an essential this is one of omega's
new watches this is the sea master
and it's got a beautiful blue face rose
gold
omega has been so fantastic to me over
the past couple press runs
and allowing me to wear their pieces so
this is just one of the most beautiful
watches i've seen in a long time
and i kind of like that the face matches
the jacket yet again
just a very timeless piece and anytime
you get to wear something that james
bond also wore
kind of makes you feel good inside i'd
kind of always been a fan of watches
but growing up in a um not as you know
well-off home it was kind of a
far-fetched stream
and so as things sort of started to
progress in my career that was always
sort of a stable piece that i wanted to
have
it just always kind of brings a smile to
my face you know it's a reminder of the
hard work that it's been over the past
couple years and
being able to take a step back and say
okay you know like you deserve something
like this or
the value for the work that you've done
with this show and
with yourself and taking the risks that
you have you know it's
nice to treat yourself i don't know man
you just put on a good watch and you
feel good
it's like putting on a well tailored
suit you know you put it on and you're
like
well like
not too bad right next up we got
tom ford exfoliating scrub and this is
a lifesaver for me so playing john b is
great but i naturally have a little bit
of facial hair so i have to wake up
every morning and shave my face
and i use this probably twice a week and
it
immediately brings my skin back to life
it helps me so much with
small breakouts i do have sensitive skin
so this is
a go-to lifesaver thank you tom ford
i'm very obsessed with this product i'm
going to embarrass myself right now
any beachgoer is going to recognize this
brand this is rainbow sandals
and i've had these shoes since i was in
eighth grade they're my
daily drivers yes those are holes in
the uh the heel areas uh the straps are
basically going to come off
if these things could talk i probably
wouldn't be able to sit here
right now with all the trouble i've
gotten in in these shoes
so like john b i've run from the cops in
these i have
we'll just we'll just leave it at that
but great sandals are great for the
beach they're great for
basically any occasion summer i've worn
them during winter months too
call me crazy it's fine but they're just
awesome sandals that
obviously last a lifetime and the best
part about them actually
is this company if i wanted to right now
i could send them right back and they
would send me a brand new pair so
super environmentally friendly i'm a big
fan i actually have another pair but
i just stick with these bad boys it's
just one of those things that i don't
think i'll ever be able to
detach from unless somebody throws them
in the trash like my girlfriend or my
mom
or my dog eats him you never know he
likes to carry things
okay so i lost him actually when i first
moved to la
i was um kind of bouncing back and forth
between people's houses
i slept in my car for a little while i
remember i had tried to condense my
entire life into my car and i'd left
like suitcases or a backpack at friends
houses and
and that was one of the items and i
remember vividly having
a panic attack because it was one thing
that i had had that was sort of a
part of my life prior to the whole
entertainment industry so
i don't remember where i found them or
how i got them back but it was
a borderline face of tears which is
super embarrassing because it's just a
shoe that has holes and
shouldn't be in my life anymore but here
we are
my next essential these bad boys amiri
sunglasses
i can't say enough about these the clear
lenses are kind of nostalgic
amir is just such a great brand he's
american designer
just like a really cool story la based
dude and
all of his stuff is just so rad so when
i got my hands on these and just the way
they fit my face
i just thought they were a little
different but different enough to fit my
style
i kind of like to uh try new things all
the time
and so what's not to love
you know it is a blue tint which
ironically matches
sort of this fantastic jacket i do like
a black frame they just
feel timeless and they feel like you can
just pair them with whatever you're
wearing
and then with a tinted lens like this
with the blue
it just i don't know i kind of feel like
iron man
and it makes my my stomach feel nice and
warm
so iron man watch out robert downey jr
i might take your sunglasses too
next essential lay labo oil diffuser
sand tall 26 which is very similar to
the 33
but i am a huge saint guy i have
literally been putting this in diffusers
for maybe two years now since i figured
it out
but i bring it with me everywhere it's
kind of one of those scents for me that
reminds me of
sort of a home base and in the
entertainment industry we travel a lot
and being gone on location you're trying
to kind of make a home away from home
so scents for me are always something
that brings me back to a specific moment
in time
and this one when i smell it honestly
what it takes me back to
is being on the water for some strange
reason and in charleston
you're constantly surrounded by the
marsh so there's like a very specific
scent and
i guess just because of where i was in
life and sort of that transitional
period
this was one of the first things where i
wasn't buying you know
diffusing oils from amazon and i decided
to splurge a little bit which
sounds ridiculous because it's just you
know an oil but it's just been something
that constantly puts me in a place of
nostalgia
so santol oil diffuser
says i should get rid of it after 12
months but i'm gonna keep it going
so my next essential is a moleskine
journal
i'm a big journaler in my personal life
for a number of reasons
um i've struggled quite a bit with my
anxiety and kind of coping with that
and uh one thing that i really connected
with through that was poetry
what i learned through poetry is if you
take the time to write it on your phone
you have the opportunity to delete
everything and you can kind of go back
and erase words
and when you put it on paper it lives
forever
so you're kind of watching your mistakes
and you're watching yourself grow
and you're able to kind of jot things
down that are a little bit again
nostalgic for whatever was going on in
that time
i've gone through kind of a lot of ups
and downs over the past couple years
with you know family members passing
away and
loss and a lot of the you know accolades
with the show and everything going on
there so
to have a physical copy of
reminding myself of the journey itself
and not allowing
social media to be a definitive factor
of where i'm at
and sort of level myself and feel
grounded that's kind of why i like to
put it down on paper versus you know
jotting it in an iphone note
i've probably got 15 000 different
notebooks laying around i like moleskins
because they're
the size of them is convenient but i
have ones that say like
chase's world plans and like just random
you know like the yellow legal pads
laying all over my house i mean i make
daily notes because if i put it on my
phone then i'll just kind of swipe
through it so
i'll even put to-do lists in my journal
just because i always have it on me so
yeah it looks cool this one's black it's
pretty sleek
i like it it's called a furminator that
is a must for any dog owner it looks a
little scary
but i have an 85 pound puppy and he
sheds
a lot like a lot so this
actually gets under the top layer of the
coat and it pulls out all of that excess
fur so this is a lifesaver
i've prayed for it for a long time and
i'm very thankful to have it in my life
i found
milo he looks like a wolf he's a german
shepherd golden retriever mix
he was from a farm in pennsylvania and
my mom and my girlfriend found him on
craigslist and i was not really looking
for a dog at the time
lo and behold i got bullied into it and
now i have an 85 pound
one-year-old dog who basically controls
everything that i do in my entire life
from the time i wake up till even when
i'm asleep i feel like he's still
controlling my brain
so it's great it's a it's a good
time-consuming activity
shedding dog big house small house you
need this bad boy
one of the most essential items in
anybody's
list is headphones but these
were a gift from a lovely friend of mine
and they are the berluti bang and olsen
collab and they are probably the coolest
headphones i've ever seen in my entire
life they are noise cancelling which is
super super clutch especially for travel
you know with work we have been
traveling quite a bit you know we shot
all through covid and having a good set
of headphones when you're trying to get
into character having a good set of
headphones when you're on the plane and
you're trying to zone out
i've been big into headspace on netflix
lately i put these bad boys on and
literally the last
i think like four or five nights i fell
asleep on my couch with these headphones
on
listening to headspace like totally
trying to get my head clear so
i am absolutely obsessed with these bad
boys they're incredible
this is a canon 90d with a sigma
35 millimeter lens i got into
photography
probably about four or five years ago i
tried to kind of start with the entry
level cameras and
as i sort of got more and more into the
workload with outer banks
all of our dps which is our director of
photographies
i just loved picking their brains so our
director jonas always lets me kind of
shadow and i sit next to him and
i've learned so much about it so i just
wanted to have a camera
that i was able to snap moments not just
at work but throughout life it just felt
like the right size it wasn't too much
of like a cinema camera it you know does
great with like sort of the
point-and-shoot stuff
it takes incredible images and in canon
i love the warm tones for them
so i think this is my second
90d because i broke the other one um
dropped it in the water oops but this
lens sigma is just incredible and then
this
strap was actually a gift from
maddie so it's kind of a cute little
reminder of
my lovely girlfriend you know i love to
hate jump ropes if i'm being completely
honest
it's one of the best forms of cardio you
can do
it in a relatively small place sometimes
you got to make it work so through kovid
you know we didn't have gyms and we had
to get really creative with our workouts
and
obviously doing a lot of the physical
activities myself i have a wonderful
stunt double named cole but
i still try to do as much as i humanly
can so for me
staying in the best shape that i can and
matching my diet with
my fitness is incredibly important
because we don't have
a small shoot window we shoot for over
half the year this season in particular
we were in barbados which was on
basically a full lockdown while we were
there so having
some form of physical activity when
you're essentially locked in a hotel
room when you're not shooting is
super super crucial so this bad boy has
served me well
and uh has left a lot of welt marks on
my arms and
my shins and my feet as well so i love
to hate that thing
that's my 10 essentials these are the
things i keep with me hope you guys
enjoyed it
and uh thanks for watching